just a recap of that breaking news we
brought you just a moment ago Russia
saying it will Annex four regions which
had held referendums earlier this week
it says it will take control of those
areas tomorrow meanwhile the European
Union and the U.S are planning to impose
more sanctions on Russia for holding
what they call Sham referendums in
Ukraine so the ballots were held in
Russian occupied parts of eastern
Ukraine the kremlin-backed authorities
there say the results show that people
overwhelmingly voted to join the Russian
Federation separatists reported huge
margins of Victory saying that in the
region of luhansk for example 98 of
Voters favored annexation
we do not accept the Sham referendum
and any kind of annexation in Ukraine
and we're determined to make the Kremlin
pay
for this further escalation so we
propose sweeping new import bans on
Russian products
this will keep Russian products out of
the European market
and deprive Russia of an additional 7
billion euros in revenues
we're also proposing to extend the list
of products that cannot be exported to
Russia anymore
the aim is here to deprive the kremlin's
military complex
of key Technologies
well there have been Russian strikes on
several areas in eastern Ukraine over
the last few days is in Ukraine's
Central City of danipra Huda we'll talk
about those strikes in a moment but
first on the news that Russia is now
announcing that it will indeed Annex
four regions which held referendums
earlier this week tell us more about
that and what happens when they actually
Annex these areas
well these four regions are uh lugans
which Russia holds nearly entirely uh
Donetsk which it doesn't it it's it's
estimated that Russia is now occupying
about 60 percent of donets and then it
occupies also half of the purija another
region further to the South and Herson
which also it's sort of one would say or
it has about 90 percent of that now I
don't think what is coming out of Russia
Today is any surprise for anyone here in
Ukraine because since before the
referendum even started anyone you would
speak to would tell you that they know
that the result has already been decided
and this is just a formality actually
one person coming out of her son told me
that this was just a theater to show to
show on the cameras so Ukraine has been
decrying that and saying that it is
legal referendum fact is that
Underground when it comes to Russia it
will say that those are now those four
regions or parts of those regions are
part of the Russian Federation it means
that it has a another border with with
Ukraine not only in the east of the
country uh next to donias but now also
in the south of the country bringing its
border much closer to Western Ukraine
much closer to where I am here in the
neighbor much closer to Kiev and it will
also in in the way Russia is laying the
ground uh change the dynamic of this war
because now Russia is saying that if
Ukraine attacks those region it will
consider it an attack on Russian
Sovereign soil and that would change the
nature of the war now people here have
been following that very closely over
the last five days dismissing yes the
results of the referendum has foregone
and but also very worried about what
could happen after especially that this
talk about mobilization of young people
for example in Zappa region in her son
right where anyone between the age of 18
and 35 young men were not allowed out
and Hunter just briefly tell us about
the strikes that took place overnight
where you were
well certainly this airstrikes have
increased over the past few days we were
in kriviri last night that is about two
hours drive from here is the hometown of
President Vladimir zielinski there's a
grain Depot that was hit there zaparita
also had several airstrikes early
morning in kharkiv last night they were
strikes too but definitely the deadliest
one was here in the nipro where I'm
standing I'm just gonna get you out this
is the crater of uh the impact really
and it's about 10 meters deep it
completely flattened about four houses
and 60 more in the surroundings are
quite damaged now we do understand that
there was a family living here a family
of four the body of three of them have
been found
some quite blown apart into pieces and
rescue workers were until very short
while ago still looking for the body of
a child who was somewhere there in this
what is now a huge crater I mean we ask
people around it well it happened around
half past 12 at night but what is really
when you speak to people what is really
sort of touching is that how they are
now
kind of resilient to what is happening
at the moment and kind of worried about
what's going to happen next after the
celebration in Moscow about the
annexation of these four regions people
are listening to President Vladimir
Putin talking about nuclear uh attack
they wonder what that means one man told
me there's nothing we can do we there is
absolutely nothing we can do if this is
what one missile can can
make as a damage what can we do if there
is a nuclear attack they take that in
the mind they worry about it and they
just waiting to see what's going to come
out of Moscow what's the next stage
coming out of Moscow thank you so much
reporting from danipro